I had a stunning Revelation this week
okay it sounds like an AI okay
how much water one [__] takes
okay what do you mean Enlighten us okay
so uh the other night we went out uh for
Sydney's birthday I had to be back by 1
30 because uh a.m yeah because they were
shutting off all the power to uh my
apartment
um to maintenance oh for like three
hours right so I was like I want to get
back I was like I don't want to walk a
bunch of stairs yeah so I don't even I
don't even know what the [__] stairs
are in my apartment I can do that they
can just shut off Powers Yeah I mean
they usually let you know like monsters
in advance but it's like right right it
is what it is and I was like oh whatever
no big deal yeah and so uh power goes
out obviously I don't even notice
because I'm fast asleep I get back by 1
30 and uh I order ubereats and the guy
arrives so that was that was good that
was like the kind of hype moment I was
like is he gonna arrive for 1 30 because
I don't know I'm I'm not walking down
those floors
I'll make him walk up them yeah I'd be
like bro just just eat it you can have
it on
um so go to sleep wake up and uh
like at eight o'clock or something this
I don't even know I had this there's
like a giant like tanoid speaker in my
apartment which the building has access
to which I didn't even know I didn't
know what this thing was because I'd
seen it on my ceiling I didn't know what
it was some announcement gets made at
like 8 A.M and I was like half asleep so
I was not paying attention by the time I
realized oh my God there's a loud
[__] voice speaking in my apartment
which is weird
uh I was like oh that's odd and then
Eugenie was staying at my house at the
time yeah I'm playing games uh with
mouse and then he goes Connor Connor I'm
like
he's like
um something's wrong with your toilet I
was like what he's like yeah something's
wrong with the toilet I'm like oh okay I
dropped a fat donkey in it I was like
he's like yeah I'm sorry I I'm like oh
bareback but guys he's Mouse on stream
and I was like all right what's wrong
he's like yeah it's not flushing so I go
to it and I feel that like when I pull
the toilet thing there's no water in the
tank yeah flush it I'm like oh that's
weird and I'm like okay well I guess let
me let me let me have a think so I'm
going around my kitchen to get some
water and I realized the water wasn't
coming on I'm like oh [__] all the
water's gone in the apartment right
there's nothing and then that's what I
realized that was what the announcement
was for
and so
now I couldn't flush the toilet but he'd
taken a [__] poop in my goddamn
toilet
so now the only way I can flush the
toilet was if I had enough water to uh
put in the water tank and then flush it
now I had to run a bath the morning
before and there's a giant bath of water
and Eugena took a bath and pulled the
goddamn plug out so my giant supply of
water that I could have used for things
is now gone right right because how the
[__] am I supposed to flush this poop
down the goddamn toilet but the problem
was as well is that I also was needing a
toilet as well and I was like oh my god
dude I don't know what to do I want to
hold it till the water comes back on and
I was like I don't know when the water's
gonna come back on and and now I started
to realize how often I needed water
because I was like oh I'll just go wash
my I can't wash my hands yeah you can't
wash my hands there's no water yeah and
then
I had I had like maybe a liter or two of
water in my fridge yeah and uh I could
have done a few things with this could
awarded my plants could have washed my
hands
um but I really wanted a coffee and so I
was like Eugene man
sorry dude I'm making I'm making a
coffee with the last water we have left
I'm making a different kind of brown
Water actually should flush the toilet I
could do some other things uh I'm gonna
make your coffee with this last one
right I would come to regret this
decision later on as I really needed a
lot of water right but as the building
kind of like realize that hey people
will need to go to the toilet still they
were offering free like bottles of water
to flush your toilet with and I was like
great so I picked up two two liter
bottles of water how long was this
maintenance going on for it was like all
day [__] yeah it's usually all day [__]
no so it was like an emergency thing it
wasn't scheduled the water wasn't
supposed to go off oh an electrical
thing yeah and like I wanted to shower
and do stuff and I don't know if you if
you guys get this sometimes you don't
you're a night person morning shower
people will probably understand the pain
of not being on a morning shower because
I just don't feel like my day is
starting yet I need to shower I feel
like I can't get any work done I can't
even start the day I can't even my brain
doesn't function sounds like it sounds
like a skill issue at least even just
wash my face I don't know why I just
need some water contact with my body
yeah um I was tempted to just go outside
and start [__] spraying myself with
Febreze to have some sensation of
jumping the roof yeah like
um but I was getting to the point where
like I could not hold my [__] any longer
right and I was like this is dangerous
game they're doubling up on the poop in
the toilet right but it was I was dying
and now a smart person would have told
you kind of just go to a convenient [__]
I was refusing to be intelligent at all
and I was like well because the
elevator's out as well right yeah yeah
so I was I was kind of like all right
um I'll just I'll just take the poop
I'll just take this poop I am I I'm sure
do the day you think about it later I'll
I'm sure the water will come back on
anytime now so I take a poop but
unfortunately this was a [__] massive
goddamn poop that I took and now now my
toilet bowl was very much too full
so
I I was like all right we gotta try and
flush this so I I got the two two liter
bottles of water so four liters of water
yeah I put it in the tank to because so
as you know that that thing fills up
with water and that uses that to push
and you know sorry I poured four liters
in I flushed the four leaders nothing it
didn't budge at all I was like holy [__]
how many liters of water do I need you
know there's an easier method that uses
less water right what so what you so I
learned about this from like you know
during like uh earthquakes or like
typhoons and stuff like that where the
water might just suddenly be cut off
yeah what you do is a lot of toilets the
the the thing that separates the the
bowl from the pipe yeah is this little
flap yeah and when you flush the toilet
the pressure from the water yeah is the
thing that opens the flap yeah so what
you do is you what you should have done
you should have gotten those two things
of water filled it in with a bucket yeah
and then flush the bucket down this the
the the bowl all at once because then
that's so much more water going into to
the ball all at once and it opens the
flap I don't know I'm I'm just saying
this is like a normal thing I'm it's
it's a southeast Asia things a lot of
toilets don't have automatic flushes
there we use the bucket technique I was
like I was like everywhere what a
universal when I heard you pouring the
water into the toilet I was like I was
like no gonna wait no no not the not the
place you poop right yeah the tank is
itself
no no no you get a bucket and you just
pour it in the place you poop and you
just oh I did that too but it was too
much how big was your [__] it was two
people's [__] and my mom was at least a
1.5 size like it was it was it was a big
one and so now this is like what would
have been maybe like even a tough flush
on a normal day yeah it'd become just
way too big of a fly right right and you
know and so and now we're starting to
smell pretty [__] bad yeah I mean
apartment it was just kind of like oh my
God so I went down again and I got uh
[__] eight [__] bottles of water
and uh I flushed it again and it didn't
[__] work and I was like I think you
just have a broken toilet I was like no
this is too big it was too big but it
did flush some of it so then I had to go
down again and get more and then finally
I managed to get it going and I was like
holy [__] I used like like 10 liters of
water to flush one [__] and now I'm now
every time I go to the toilet and I
flush I'm like that's a lot of water I
just wasted like I feel bad I'm like I
drink less water than I flush down the
drain every day well I mean like I'm I'm
used to not flushing every single time
because in Australia like we're in a
drought like yeah all the time right so
they actually teach kids being like if
it's yellow let it mellow if it's brown
flush it down
you know what I'm talking about right I
don't
know he's like to uh to the only other
Australian yeah you know what I'm
talking about
but that's how I was told because it's
like you don't want to waste water
because you use as you found out yes a
shitload of water to flush the toilet
it's literally a [__] I knew it was a
lot of water but I guess just visually
having to pour that much water in to
have one [__] was like oh my God yeah
people must feel like when they find out
like first first of all people when they
find out like poverty exists like oh my
God they live like these damn [__] like
I obviously like I was familiar with how
Plumbing works but I think I think the
the Strat that you should have done is
you should have not taken the [__] on
top of the [__] no that was me that was
me being pretty gung-ho about it yeah I
was like it'll come back on any time
though and it and it didn't come on
until like 6 p.m yeah right so I was
like this [__] sucks yeah it was out
all day right um so that was kind of
shitty okay like what's the longest
you've gone without a shower or a bath
because uh one week
one week I'm sure there was a long
period that I can't remember right right
because like I I remember there would be
some points right where you know it's
you know the water was working but in
England uh we'd have a boiler and you
know for some reason the boilers are
always spoilers if someone takes one
[__] bath and it's like all right no
one gets to have hot water yeah no no
one gets off
we'll wait like two hours what a [__]
system yeah yeah yeah so sometimes the
boiler just doesn't work and you know
sometimes it you have to wait a while to
get like Plumbing there and uh the the
planets like either replace the boiler
or fix it or something so you'd uh you
know that would be like sometimes two
two like a two-week stint where I just
would not have any hot water right like
do you are you okay showering cold
shower
if I have no choice yes yeah yeah even
if it's in England in the winter
maybe not yeah because like I
I I remember that like the boiler would
always obviously like break at always
like the worst points and uh I remember
it's at one point I just got started
getting used to it and I didn't take
cold showers but I I did feel like I had
brought like let's say the second third
world country experience to England
because what we'd have is we'd have like
we we just bought like extra like
massive pots and pans it would hit about
like 6 p.m and my dad's like does anyone
want a shower
yeah yeah I'd be like I'd be like oh
yeah I'm I'm planning to showering about
now and my dad like brings out like the
we had like uh we we had like four like
stoves so we bring out like four massive
pots start fitting up with cold water
and start like boiling our hot water for
like the evening which is what we'd use
it's got to be so inefficient compared
to a boiler probably is very very much
very very inefficient how do people live
like that oh no man for me for me it was
like a week uh it wasn't so much like I
didn't want to take a cold shower it's
just we didn't have water to shower
because I was out in the middle of
[__] no way camping for a week yeah
so it's like the water is very scarce
because we're very far away from
civilization so it's like we're gonna
save this Australia and it's Australia
so we're going to use this water to
drink and so I had no choice but to just
not shower for a week and then when I
got home and I had that shower I felt
like I was born again I was like ah all
my sins were just getting washed away
for not showering for a week never again
though yeah isn't it like was it Johnny
Harris that made a video where he was
like didn't shower or didn't shampoo
okay okay because I didn't know people
in dreadlocks like first time
because I didn't know if it was the
science where it's like better to not
shower or if it's better to not wash
your hair I think I think there's a few
things again we could be all lying yeah
chatting out of our ass but I think
they're like I think showering or at
least washing your body with a shirt
every day is unnecessary yeah because it
gets rid of like the oil yeah you know
you don't need to you don't need to
shampoo every day either yeah no I think
shampoo they say you should maybe do
like twice a week but even then I think
it's like contentious I can't remember
yeah it depends on your skin uh like uh
yeah